hey guys my name is jeff mcdonald it's
the 21st of july today you're watching
games what news and it's the slowest
news day in the history of slow news day
so let's talk about some weird stuff
first up in said weird stuff the last
bus is going to be a stage show and yes
you absolutely heard that right alright
so it's really an event called the last
of us one night live and will feature
many of the actors performing select
scenes from the game alongside music
from the games composer the voices
behind Joel Ellie Marlene Sarah and Tess
will all be present and co-director Neil
druckmann will serve as the show's
director if you'd like to go you can get
a free ticket off the PlayStation
website it's going to be held in Santa
Monica next monday that's july 28 not to
worry if you don't find yourself in
california though as the event will be
live streamed although there's no word
yeah don't will be playing the role of
the clickers next up doom 4 which is
really just called doom in the same vein
of confusing names as tomb raider
SimCity and xbox one may not be
resurfacing for a while the game was
shown at quakecon in there was gameplay
and it was a whole thing but apparently
it's unlikely to make its way into game
his hands oh I holes anytime soon PR and
marketing blast for bethesda Pete Hines
has said the game isn't ready for a
proper reveal since it's still very much
in progress pine said we don't want to
stream to go up for a game that isn't at
the point where we would formally show
it to the world and now that the thing
is getting picked apart and digested and
gone through frame by frame and getting
nitpick to death when we wouldn't
normally be showing this to anybody at
all at the same time he expressed that
they wanted to put something out there
to prove that they are working hard on
the title and are doing their best to
give the doom name the care and respect
it deserves if you came for a game
that's gonna push your pc to its limits
than you may be interested in the fact
that upcoming space game elite dangerous
is launching with settings that can't be
run on current pc hardware david Braben
the head of dev frontier developments
told Eurogamer we're going through some
wonderful effects internally that looked
truly beautiful and we're saying that's
is the frame rate a bit doesn't it and
we say yes but we don't mind because it
looks so beautiful about what we're
going to do is attach it to this part of
the detail slider or we'll call it out
at the tick box even if your PC of today
can't run with all the features on your
PC of tomorrow night and I'll see your
question of the day let me know which of
your favorite games you'd want to see
morphed into a stage show and why if you
like conventions and livestream goodness
and it's well worth you knowing that san
diego comic-con is a thing that's
happening this week we will be having a
to our lab sure from thursday through
saturday starting at 4pm PT each day so
visit gamespot to get stuck into that
for all the info and whatnot that is it
from me and your Monday Joseph news I'll
be back tomorrow same time and place
with a bunch more gamey bits and pieces